je préfère garder ma vie pour pour moi
même mais bon je pense qu'effectivement
la campagne est lancée oui alors celui
qui sait lui c'est lui qui décide du
moment opportun je sais pas non non je
vais pas m'immiscer la barre s'il est
celle utilisée dès que sa maman portait
un groupe en avril est en train campagne
à cheveux rue bah oui je pense que c'est
un peu sa manière à lui de montrer qu'il
est là un peu partout ça permet
justement à ces territoires qui sont
moins touchés par la politique de se
remobiliser et de montrer qu'il y porte
un intérêt donc pourquoi pas toucher des
potentiels électeurs
oui je pense qu'il commence sa campagne
électorale qu'est-ce qu'il faut fait
dire ça en fait qu'un le fait justement
qu'il aille un petit peu voir tout le
monde qu'il sorte de sa réserve
je pense que c'est le moment de toute
façon parce que les élections sont dans
combien de temps
dans moins de nom bientôt les élections
se rapproche donc si on veut se
présenter il faut se faire mieux
connaître disons parce que les français
le connaissent mais peut-être qu'il va
donner un autre visage de lui même je ne
sais pas je n'ai peut-être pas ce qu'il
y avait de mieux à faire je ne sais pas
pour dire que moi je ne suis pas jeune
donc je ne connais pas carlito et je
n'ai pas comment il s'appelle l'autre
mcfly et carline voilà voilà
oui c'est le moment oui parce que c'est
normal d'avoir un contact avec les gens
un peu partout
voilà bah oui sûrement parce que six
balades de partout c'est pour pouvoir
voir un peu le peuple et essayer de
gagner des points partout donc je pense
oui il aurait dû le faire avant je pense
après c'est peut-être un peu trop tard
mais oui il vaut mieux plus de faim tard
que jamais mais il aurait peut-être dû
le faire avant
je pense que c'est bien qu'il aille dans
des départements qui sont
moins importants comme le comme celui du
lot à partir du moment où on marque on
ne sait pas bouger
quasiment dans toute la france pendant
pratiquement trois ans quatre ans qu'il
a eue les gilet jaune eu beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ont manifesté leur
mécontentement et contentement pardon
contre le sa politique et que maintenant
monsieur essaye de faire le petit
j'oserais dire si je n'oserais derrière
le petit père des peuples
on a en commençant par le lot et en
finissant peut-être par l'ardèche le
cantal voir le voir la haute savoie
c'est pas comme ça qu'il y aura des voix
dans la mesure où déjà au niveau des
régionales c'est pour moi très mal parti
pour lui parce que c'est le moment pour
lui après c'est une bonne chose qui se
montre auprès des citoyens à la télé de
la visibilité ça peut être bien pour
redorer son image un petit peu il a
besoin de redorer son image
je pense c'est finalement début de
campagne
il ne le cache pas d'ailleurs il fait
des nominations il promet des monts et
merveilles aux jeunes qu'il a ignoré
jusque là oui effectivement
ça sent la campagne tout sans la
compagnie président république doit
laisser le peuple décider tout seul en
son âme et conscience par rapport à des
gens qui se présente c'est pas lui qui
se présente qui sont des personnes
locales que les gens apprécient pour
leurs sacs en général s'ils sont déjà
connus maintenant ceux qui sont pas
connus ceux de la raim effectivement vu
qu'ils ne sont pas connus bain
il essaye de se faire connaître tant
bien que mal avec la pluie du président
et pourtant c'est pas sa place il
devrait avoir une couverture